Sorry, I was too busy saying my shit that I didn't realize the starting speech was about to end.
All I'm saying is, why would you pay a ticket to sit in a seat to watch trailers?
I don't understand!
I was like, why are there people sitting there in the audience?
You don't need the audience!
You're literally just watching trailers!
Like, I understand if it's the Game Awards, you know?
Because they're awarding stuff, but...
But there is literally just a summer game fest!
There's so many people there too!
And it's live!
Maybe they're paid actors.
Oh, just like the Oscars.
I don't know if you guys know this.
Oh, that's true.
There might be demos to play.
But yeah, but a lot of them...
A lot of demos are released on Steam.
So, yeah.
A lot of demos are already going to be released on Steam right after.
Just like the Oscars.
I don't know if you guys know this, but in the Oscars, they actually have paid...
They have paid actors that sit on the chair to make it so that the seats aren't empty.
So it could just be like the Oscars.
So should we get to the games?
Alright, it all begins right now.
Yeah, it's true.
It's true.
Here's our first announcement.
When people have to do bathroom breaks in the Oscars, they actually...
Wait, Lego.
Nice.
But there's always a Lego game, so I'm not as hyped.
But in the Oscars, if people go to the bathroom, they bring in paid actors.
Actual paid actors to go and sit in the seat so it looks like it's not empty.
Even during, like, bathroom breaks.
Hey, what game is this anyway?
What game?
Yeah, what game is it?
Are they gonna bring back GTA Legos?
What's this?
Oh, it's that girl!
The one I played one playthrough of and then stopped.
Horizon, yeah!
This dog guy is Aloy.
An amazing video game lead.
A thunder jar went mad and his terror threw the valley.
Don't worry, I'll bring it down.
Oh my god!
Genshin... The girl in Genshin Impact, guys!
A lonely hero, hunting machines all by herself.
Hello!
I have friends, you know.
Let's do this!
Right.
A friendly hero, hunting with her...
Is that it?
Why does this game need a Lego game?
That's actually... I mean, okay.
All I'm saying is like, I don't think Horizon needed a Lego game.
This is what I want!
I am the two people that wanted this!
Who asked for this?
Marble asked for this, guys!
Marble is one of the two people that filled in the feedback form for Lego crossovers.
Everything needs a Lego spaceship.
Just play Fortnite, it's free.
It's free Lego.
Father, thank you for the Twitch Prime!
Thank you, thank you!
Hey guys, I know we said rest week, but in the end, it was more so of...
It was more so of like Twitch week instead.
Oh, it's on... Is it only on the Switch?
There you go.
Wasn't that fun?
That was Lego Horizon Adventures.
Coming out later this year for PlayStation 4.
But also day one on PC and Nintendo Switch.
Oh, okay.
Day one on PC.
I was gonna be like, that's fucked up.
If it's only on the Switch.
But like, also, who asked for this?
...from Torn Banner Studios, the developers behind Chivalry 2.
For their next project, they are proud to announce No More Room in Hell 2.
The sequel to the 2011 award-winning Source mod.
Eight players start separate in the dark, and it's up to you to find your...
Wait, I've heard of this game.
...and survive with permadeath.
Here is the first one.
Tokidok Dispotential Sponsors.
Wait, I've heard of this game.
But like, I also don't remember, because it was like 2011.
Yeah, yeah, it's a zombie game.
I remember.
It was like a mod.
Yeah, it's like super... Oh!
Oh my god, are we bringing all the old zombie games?
All the old zombie mods?
Which one was the other one?
The other two.
Are we bringing them back?
Is it zombie games again?
Are we ditching space games and going back to zombies?
Yes!
Bring back DayZ!
Bring back DayZ 2!
Zombie meta!
Bring back zombie meta!
Permadeath.
Come full circle!
What was the other one?
There was like another one.
There's the other zombie mod.
Oh yeah, Arma!
Bring back Arma 2!
Early access Halloween 2024.
Oh my god, we're bringing it back!
We're bringing back zombies!
To introduce our next game, please join me in welcoming someone who I've known for over a decade.
She's been a huge fan of some of our reveals like Street Fighter 6 a few years ago, and of course Final Fantasy 7 Rebirth last year when she was sitting in the audience.
Well this year, she's joining us on stage.
H1Z1, yeah!
Bring back H1Z1!
Bring back DayZ!
Bring back H1Z1, DayZ, and every zombie game out there.
Thank you, Jeff!
Hi everyone, I am so excited to be here at Summer Game Fest.
Mushi!
I'm here with you today to share some even more super fun trailers.
So, let's get straight to another world premiere.
Yeah, I heard that Jeff said that we shouldn't be too hyped for Summer Game Fest.
Because, like, there's not a lot of games being developed.
Because, they won't say it, but a lot of people got fired.
He didn't say why!
Why there's not a lot of games being released this year!
But I'll say it.
There were a lot of layouts.
Yeah, Jeff.
Why is there not a lot of keys being released, Jeff?
Why does the graphics look like shit?
I'm sorry.
But, like, is this a mobile game?
Is this a mobile game?
Quidditch Champions...
There's no way this is a PC game.
This is on PlayStation?
Guys, this looks so good...
Bro, okay, but imagine playing this on a PlayStation 5.
Ha-ha-ha-ha!
Oh, the polygons.
This is the next gen.
What the fuck?
What?
Guys, it's okay.
You're gonna make us stronger by watching...
What the...
What is this?
What?
Oh my god, he dropped the soap.
I was like, what?
Guys, guys, they're making us stronger.
So like, they're like lowering our expectations.
In the beginning.
So that, by the time...
Like, you know, near the end.
Like, we'll take anything.
This is what they're doing.
This is exactly what they're doing.
I can feel it.
Oh yeah, this is definitely gonna be a VTuber game.
This is like a streamer bait game, 100%.
This is not for the regular players.
This is for streamers only.
There's no way.
Like, I'm confused looking at this.
But I know it's gonna be a...
Just a fun streamer game.
New flavor of the month, yeah.
What the?
I'm just...
I'm just confused.
The helicopter has been stolen?
What?
But...
Your fucking fellow prisoners can blow you up?
What?
Just so you know...
The Summer Game Fest is sponsored, by the way.
So this is endorsed by...
This is endorsed by Jeff.
Oh, I can tell.
I can...
I can tell.
From Ubisoft and Lucasfilm Games.
The first open-world Star Wars game where you live the life of a scoundrel.
On Monday at 12pm Pacific, you'll get to see a full gameplay showcase during Ubisoft's third event.
I was surprised they let that final shot be in the trailer.
For, you know...
We've got an exclusive new glimpse at the game.
I'm pretty...
For like people who are watching this.
Like, you know...
And then like having a sponsor sponsor this watch-a-long.
Or like this Summer Game Fest.
I was very surprised it showed.
Especially when, you know, some game companies that are sponsoring this might not be based in America.
That might have very tough rules regarding stuff like that.
I was so confused.
Is this Ubisoft?
Tune in.
August 30th.
Oh, it's not EA.
If it was EA, I could be like, can I have early access?
There's so many people in the audience!
I hope they get to watch for free.
I hope they don't have to pay for a ticket.
I had a chance to play through this next game and I have to say, it is really spectacular.
Neva comes from Nomada Studio.
The creators of the Game Award winning game, Grease.
It chronicles the story of Alba...
Yeah, like we're watching for free.
They have to sit next to all the other gamers.
...at the gameplay.
And like, still watch a screen.
We're all looking at the same screen.
I don't understand.
God, I hope they didn't have to pay to like sit there.
Oh, that's true.
They might get small gift bags and then like sell it on eBay.
You know how like Blizzard like give like those gifts where like if you work for the dev team for like an X amount of years, you get gifted like special items.
And then like you can find majority of those items on eBay.
Yeah, it's an actual thing and then they put and then they sell it on eBay.
You can find like majority.
Like it's supposed to be like if you work in Blizzard for like 10 years, you get like a sword or something.
And then like somebody put that sword on eBay.
Yeah, if you get five, you also get those items.
Looks really pretty.
It looks really pretty and it looks like a game that I won't be playing.
But others will enjoy it.
You guys can be like, it looks so pretty but I know some of you guys won't even play it.
...tons of fun to play.
And there's much more coming later today in the Devolver Direct, which will air directly after the Day of the Devs on this same stream.
So we got lots more for you.
I'm never gonna play that.
Right next, it's time for our next game announcement.
What's this?
Guys, they're lowering our expectations.
So like they're actual, they're like really good games.
Might not be that impressive when we have our expectations high.
But now that our expectations are so low.
Like we'll be like, whoa!
Is this Civ?
It looks like Civ.
Wait, is it?
Oh my god, see?
It's working!
People are going crazy right now!
I knew it!
It's working!
It's already working!
People are already going crazy!
Civ, you did it again!
I mean, it has to be Civ.
There's a rocket now.
Civ 7!
2025.
Jesus.
Oh my god, he's so old!
Someone put him in a home?
I'm sorry.
Sorry.
It's like a grandpa!
Double down, Toki!
I'm just saying, like, we gotta get some new blood in here.
And we hope you'll join us later this summer.
I didn't realize...
Okay, okay, I'm gonna be truthful for you guys.
In the meantime...
I didn't even think he was alive.
I'm sorry.
I legitimately thought he...
Like, I thought the game was so old.
I legitimately thought he wasn't alive anymore.
Oh my god, is this Wukong?
Oh my god, is this Dead Souls Wukong?
In the Black Mists!
Okay, but, like, you gotta admit, I'm pretty sure, like, Cid is, like, just like a...
What is the word called?
He's just there to be, like, a figurehead.
Like, just to be the face of the company.
I'm pretty sure he's not actually making the...
The new decisions anymore for the newer Civ games.
Only because I feel like...
Since it's like...
Um...
You know, it's like...
You gotta get in new blood.
But they still...
They're like, oh my god, it's Cid!
You know it's gonna be good because Cid is still endorsing it.
God, it looks so good.
Too bad this is just all cinematics and not gameplay trailers.
Okay.
Okay, I'm, like, a little bit conflicted.
Because they're only showing cinematics.
And it's releasing in August.
But they're still showing cinematics.
So, like, that's the only thing that I'm really concerned about.
Like...
That's like...
You know, if you don't have gameplay trailers and it's releasing in August...
I'm concerned.
It looks pretty.
The cinematics looks pretty.
Is this a VR game?
Oh my god, it's like that...
Oh my god, it was...
Yeah, it was like that.
Aliens VR trailer.
And everybody was like, what the fuck is the frame rate?
Yeah, I know they showed gameplay trailers in the past.
But the fact that we aren't showing more gameplay trailers at this stage is concerning.
Because cinematics, it should be something that's shown, like, when there's, like, you know, a year before released or something.
But at this point, when there's still a few...
Like, there's, like, less...
Like, around two to three months.
Until release day.
It should just be gameplay trailers.
What's this?
Oh, I remember!
I remember!
There was an early access of this.
There...
It was...
It's some, like...
Spooky game.
Spooky shooter...
Looter shooter game.
Yeah.
July 9th?
I just heard, like, barely anything.
Yeah, one is human.
This...
This had an early access.
I'm pretty sure.
I remember seeing people play...
Playing it.
And I was like,
oh, I don't know.
Oh, hey, turnip!
Boy!
Have any of you faced Tyranids before?
Only these past two days.
Then there is much to learn.
I can't wait for this one.
Space Marine?
Space Marine looks so good.
It reminds me of Gears of War.
That's why I think it's going to be really good.
Because it looks so similar to Gears of War.
And I think it's going to be really good.
I feel like it's gonna be like a spiritual successor.
I mean like Warhammer's been around for a while, but like, I mean like gameplay wise, it can be sort of like a spiritual successor to Gears of War.
All right, welcome back to Summer Game Fest.
We've got some amazing developer guests joining us throughout the show, and I'm very excited to introduce our first guests.
They are legendary creators who are working on a brand new fantasy RPG metaphor slated to launch this October.
Please welcome the director and art designer of Persona 3, 4, and 5, Katsura Hashino and Shigemori Sojima.
Oh shit.
I like how somebody was like, Persona.
And then someone was like, Ohmaga Kojumbo.
Guys, wrong company.
Guys, not everybody that wears glasses is Kojumbo.
Thank you everybody.
It is a pleasure to be here.
I know he's wearing glasses and has a similar haircut.
It's a pleasure to be here with Mr. Sojima.
This game is a RPG in which party members- An arPEgE?!
No way.
these archetypes allow you to fight against- Oh my god.
An arPG?
An arPG.
An RPG?
No fucking way.
Alice is making an RPG?
Archetypes are the embodiment of power born from the will to face your fears and anxieties.
Breaking the mold.
Slow down there, Atlas.
We don't want too much innovation in a minute.
What is going on?
In total, there will be more than 40 types of archetypes available in the game.
These archetypes can gain experience and even evolve.
Some of them can evolve into stronger versions.
Alice, make it an FPS game.
Do it.
Do I know balls?
So we are pouring all of our acquired expertise into this game to make it as exciting as possible.
In fact, we've even brought our latest trailer today, which is centered around the topic of these archetypes.
Thank you very much, and we hope you enjoy it.
Isn't archetypes basically Persona?
But like, oh my god, Persona boy!
Oh, it's a helm.
Oh my god!
It's Persona boy!
In Persona 3!
Yeah, Persona 3 boy!
Sorry, Archetype boy.
Bro,
it's literally Persona 3 boy!
He actually just looks like him!
He just has, like, two different eye colors.
You must acquire more archetypes and bring them together.
So, like...
How's this?
Scour!
No holding back!
Why can't I just make Persona 7?
Now you've acquired a most interesting power.
An archetype whose existence was only theoretical.
You wield power now.
Yeah, it's fantasy Persona.
Sorry, Persona... I lost.
This is Persona 7.
They skipped 6.
Let's see.
Metaphor.
I'm surprised I could read that.
Such an honor to have Hashino and Tsujima with us on stage.
I mean, it's gonna be good, I'm pretty sure.
Like, Atlas cannot really fuck up the, like, the formula regarding Persona.
They just took Persona and, like, changed the name a little bit.
As Batman, you face a new threat.
The mysterious Rat King and his cultish devotees.
There's no way!
I don't think they've ever made a bad Persona game.
That's, like, RPG.
I know they've made bad Persona games that aren't RPG games.
But, like, I meant, like, I don't think they've actually made a bad Persona game.
There's a new darkness overtaking Gotham.
Leap Persona Dash Alone!
You're, like, one out of the ten people that actually played that game.
Yeah!
Oh, hey, Batman.
Wait, is this a VR game?
Arkham Shadow.
Only on MetaQuest 3.
Bro!
Stop letting Facebook buy you off!
Stop taking Facebook money!
Who the fuck owns it?
The Valve 3D thing.
If MetaQuest keeps fucking getting all the exclusives.
I'm looking forward to heading back to the Arkhamverse.
Now, it is time to update fans on a legendary fighting game franchise.
And that includes me.
Because I have been a fan of this series ever since one of its first iteration and have been playing each one ever since.
So, let's check it out.
Wait, what is this?
What the fuck is this?
Is this Street Fighter?
He has this...
What the fuck is he doing?
Wait, is this Street Fighter?
Terry.
I recognize the shirt and pants only because...
From like Street Fighter...
What is it?
Marvel versus...
Marvel versus Capcom?
Bison is alive?
I don't know any of the...
I feel like fighting game lore is like...
So complicated.
I'm really surprised people can't keep up with it.
Oh, so they're adding new characters into Street Fighter.
Wait, Terry was not in Street Fighter?
I thought Terry was like very...
I thought Terry was like...
OG.
Oh, Terry is from SNK.
What?
Wait.
Terry's not in Street Fighter?
Wait, why do I remember Terry?
Terry.
Why the fuck do I remember Terry?
Oh, SNK versus Capcom.
Oh.
No, it wasn't from Smash.
I remember the 2D Terry.
See, I'm not the only one.
Fads also thought Terry was Street Fighter.
No, I remember like the 2D guy.
Like, when he was like 2D.
What is this?
Okay, you know what's funny?
Super chats are on for the...
For the Summer Game Fest stream.
And people are actually super chatting it.
And I'm like, why?
I don't think the money's gonna go to the developers.
Like, yeah.
Yeah, people are super chatting the stream.
But like...
It's not gonna go to the developers.
Just for chat.
Oh shit, Goku.
Is this a new Dragon Ball Z fighting game?
It's like going to a...
To like, I guess, Jeff?
Cause he's getting sponsored to show...
Getting paid and sponsored to show trailers?
I mean, I think it's...
Just like I see that.
One
way to save her.
The graphics look ass.
I'm sorry.
True.
Are you blind?
I've seen better graphics for Dragon Ball Z.
In older games.
I feel like the older Dragon Ball Z games had better graphics.
Like, Sad Land had...
Okay, Sad Land...
Had better graphics.
And it's the same style.
You can't...
You can't say that.
We're literally playing Sad Land.
There you go, internet.
We got two release dates for fucking zero October 11th.
And it's the same style.
And the graphics are so good.
Now we step in the world of Delta Force Hawk Ops.
A free to play tactical shooter available to play on all platforms.
Here's a look at their multiplayer FPS extraction mode.
Sad Land is on...
Sad Land's still 3D.
We've got a new mission.
It's the new Tarkov.
The new Tarkov.
The situation is zero damage.
The conflict is escalating between Havangor and Al-Sarra Guard.
It's time to take action.
Objection.
Collect and decode the Mandelbrot located at the tourist center on the southeast region.
We need to utilize Tarrace and splendid search...
Why are they bad things?
Like, why are there so many boring extractions?
It's because extraction shooter...
It's because they heard Tarkov is like going up in flames, so they're all trying to make the new Tarkov.
Quick recovery, quick recovery.
Because like they saw the hole in the... they saw the hole in the system so they're trying to make a new Tarkov to grab the Tarkov players.
Because the only extraction shooters people are playing is only Tarkov.
So everybody's just trying to make the next Tarkov.
This looks like Payday.
It's an extraction shooter so it could be... it's like a mix of Call of Duty and like extraction shooter.
I mean remember when Tom Clancy made an extraction shooter and how fast that died?
I'm very pessimistic because like we've had like a two or three years of sort of low-key bad games.
Like from AAA.
From AAA titles.
From AAA companies.
We've had like, you know, we had like two or three years of like bad AAA game titles.
All right.
Educate me on the Dragon Ball Z game.
The new game.
People were so like surprised I said that.
I just thought the graphics looked like...
like I've seen better Dragon Ball Z graphics for other games.
So I was just like, man, does it look just so TK?
We have seen it on stream.
And now I have an update for you on Fatal Fury City of the Wolves.
Oh, is it a remake?
Is that a remake of the game?
That's the Budokai style?
Oh, it's a... it's a sequel.
Oh.
Oh, wait, is this in the Street Fighter?
Is it time for more Terry?
It's Terry!
It's SNK!
What does SNK sound for?
I just said it because everybody else was saying it.
It's the Terry game!
So far,啦.
Oh, it's the
name of the company.
I knew that.
Oh wait, I know this!
I remember the minigames.
Wait, what's this?
Is this a VR game?
Is this a VR game but for a meta?
Exclusive in meta?
Love more in... what?
Oh, is this a sponsor?
A new standard.
OLEDs.
Oh, it's for monitors.
Hey guys, you wanna know what monitors I have?
So instead of buying this...
People calling this an ad when this entire... That's true.
This entire convention...
This entire watch-along is an ad for Jeff.
But then they added an ad within an ad.
You know they paid to be in there.
What is this?
What the heck is this?
Sorry, what the hell is this?
I'm not playing Minecraft anymore.
Is this a mobile game?
The Final Battle?
Oh, this is a mobile game.
Mobile gamers watch...
Summer Game Fest?
They watch...
My mom is not watching April.
Hey, grandpa!
Give me mod on your channel.
You first.
You mod me first.
What's this?
It's a mecha game, but what is it?
Guys, I know it's a mecha game.
I may be stupid, but I can still see.
I was like, what is this game?
And so my chat was like, it's a mecha game, Toki.
Like, I know it's a mecha game.
Close beta test coming in.
Mecha...
Oh, wow.
Look.
Mecha Break.
We're back here at Summer Game Fest.
Is that new IP?
Look at Mecha Break with its immersive aerial and ground combat with lightning fast maneuvers.
Next, Jason Blum...
Is this a mecha battle royale?
... with incredible horror films over the years, like Get Out, Megan, and last year's Five Nights at Freddy's.
Well, now Blumhouse is entering the video game world.
I never heard of it.
I hope it doesn't fail like that Gundam one.
That's sad.
That Gundam one could have been a really good game.
I'm so sad that it actually got shut down.
I feel like if they invested more into perfecting it, or like patches and stuff...
What is this?
Wait.
What?
Why is it pixels?
What is it?
What?
Oh, are these like...
... worse Freddy?
Oh, they're different games!
Sleep Awake from Iso.
I thought it was all one game.
I was so surprised.
Don't worry, Viv.
I was like...
How did it go from 3D to Horror Stardew Valley?
What is this style joke?
It's several games.
This looks like a different game.
Should have some developer mode.
I was like...
How did we go from shooting dolls to Horror Stardew Valley?
It depicts the farming.
It was not clear to me in the beginning until it like...
Gave a different game title.
Blumhouse Games.
Oh, it all came from one studio.
Wait, they're releasing all of that?
Oh, that's a lot of games that they're releasing.
I hope one of them is good.
Okay.
Is it?
Please welcome Jason Blum, CEO and founder of Blumhouse.
Yeah, that's a lot.
And he's playing creatively at Blumhouse Games.
Yeah, isn't Blumhouse a fucking movie studio?
When did they start...
When did they start making games?
We got ourselves a full slate there.
That's incredible.
So, Jason, tell us a bit about...
Why did you want to get into games like this?
What are we doing?
Well, we've been very, very busy.
I'm very happy to be here.
Thank you.
Thank you for having us.
Thank you guys all.
Great to hear the fans out there.
Oh, they're publisher.
Oh, they just...
They funded.
Oh, I see.
They published them.
You'll all be very happy to know we're working at this very minute on the sequel of Five Nights at Freddy's.
It's coming.
Don't worry.
Yeah, I was like, didn't they make FNAF?
Anyway, horror is...
They make the FNAF movie?
...to my great relief.
It's getting more and more popular.
Our movies are working.
It's working on streaming.
It's working in live events.
Well, you hope they're working.
We wanted to try and make it happen.
We wanted to try and take our approach to movies and apply it to games.
And that's what you see here.
We're going to do independent games.
We're going to look for creators and give them a platform and encourage these creators to be weird and subversive and find the most FNAF scary things they can and put them into really cool games.
It's like a...
What is it?
A shotgun tactic.
They look great.
It's really fun.
As many indie horror games as they can.
Tell us a bit about it.
We saw a bunch of games.
It will be the next FNAF.
Well, as you just saw from our slate, our horror games are a lot like Blumhouse movies.
They come in many different flavors of fear, which means there's a horror game for everyone.
So maybe you're a fan of nostalgic, 90s, 90s, a bit more intense, first-person shooters.
I don't think that's as big of a compliment as you think it is.
Because I think FNAF was one of their...
As horror fans, one of their...
Was like their most popular.
And our independent development partners are the same, and they're just as excited, which means we've got psychological nightmares, we have supernatural scares, we have cosmic horror.
And our team has worked really hard to work with global, creative, talented partners.
And that means for us that we...
Oh wait, they did get out?
Okay.
Let me see it there.
Blumhouse.
Yeah.
Which means that we can take risks.
They did Megan.
We can be flexible.
The breakdancing doll.
And maybe we can push the limits of what's possible.
Do you guys remember Megan?
We're so excited.
Yeah.
The breakdancing doll.
It looks awesome, all the stuff you have there.
I know we'll get into when games are coming out, but some of these are coming soon, Jason, right?
We've got a good slate.
Well, yeah.
We're on PC and console.
And we wanted to start with not just one, but we wanted to start with a few games.
For those who don't know, Megan was in the YouTube trailers, it was horror film.
Fear the Spotlight is a fresh release.
Yeah.
The message was that the theme for it was obviously the horror film.
But Megan was honestly more so of a comedy film than a horror film.
Because she just starts fucking breakdancing.
It's like, yeah, it's a horror comedy.
But the movie trailers were all super serious.
But then when you watch the film, she starts breakdancing.
Well, I know this is just the start, so we'll probably be seeing you in future years with more from Live Long House Games.
You guys, what do you think of the slate?
Pretty amazing, right?
The YouTube trailers made it look like a really bad movie.
It's a fucking scary film.
Thank you, guys.
All right.
You guys never seen the breakdancing dog?
And now here's the world premiere of a brand new Power Rangers game with a retro film.
Wait, what?
A Power Rangers game?
They made Tooth Fairy?
Wait, all they do is make horror films.
They are the shotgun tactic.
Because they have some really bad horror films.
Oh my God.
They've made some really bad horror films, too.
Oh, it's like a Teenage Mutant Ninja Turtles game.
Oh my God.
It's like the Teenage Mutant Ninja one.
Go go Power Rangers.
Gotta miss that theme song.
I think my favorite Power Ranger series was the animal one.
That one I was super obsessed with.
What's this?
Is her mom dead?
Oh my god, her mom's dead.
It's just like Bambi.
Oh my god, it's so cute!
It's so cute!
I'm never gonna play it, but it looks so cute!
Hey guys, thank you for the donation!
Thank you, thank you!
Wait, what the fuck?
Oh my god, he's growing up like Simba!
How many years has it been?
Oh my god, it's like spirited away!
Wait, no, is it spirited away?
No, princess is spirited away!
Princess Mononoko!
Yeah, it's like Princess Mononoke!
Deer and Boy.
I love the name.
It's very direct.
Yeah, I was like, wait, it's not spirited away, it's the other animal one.
Oh my god, he did this by himself?
Oh, okay.
That's funny.
I'm sorry, I thought it was funny that the French government funded this.
Kingdom Come Deliverance 2 is arriving later this year.
This is a first person open world action RPG from Warhorse Studios.
Sponsored by France!
Thanks, France!
The best laid plans of men don't always come to fruition.
Man proposes.
What's this?
God disposals.
And then boots you right in the balls.
These two young fellows, I need to find them.
One's a smart ass smith, and the other's a blue blooded fledgling.
You behave like a spoiled boy!
What's this?
Kingdom Come 2?
Gah...
Gentlemen, praise me to the king.
Oh my god, there's horses!
I'm sold.
What the fu- Okay.
This is the moment where people rewind on that specific moment.
You know on like YouTube, there's like, uh, where do people replay the section of a video?
I bet you if they publish this trailer on YouTube, it will hit- it will be that part.
The bonus replay!
With the Kingdom Come trailer.
Kingdom Come 2!
Deliverance!
Oh, 2024!
It's not that long.
I've never played the first one.
No, of course not.
Did you play the first one?
No, but I'm just a sheep.
Back in 2021, we announced his new game, Slitherhead, at the Game Awards.
I'm excited because you guys are excited.
I'm a blank slate that you can put your excitement on.
What game is this Slitherhead made?
Wait, what's- what's Slitherhead?
Oh, it's Silent Hill?
Director Silent Hill?
Oh!
Okay, that actually freaked me out.
Wait, is this based off of- Is this based off of- I don't want to say it because I'm scared I'm wrong.
But like, this is- Is this Hong Kong?
Is
this Hong Kong?
Yeah, is this Hong Kong?
I saw- I saw red taxis.
What the fuck?
Yeah, no, this is Hong Kong!
The bus!
The green bus!
Wait, I think it is!
I saw the green bus!
The minibus!
Okay, I'm going to play it because it's based off of Hong Kong.
What the fuck is that?
I thought it was like- I don't want to say it because if it's not, I'd be very embarrassed.
I'm not scared of like horror games if you can shoot it.
Okay, that's a lie because Dead Space fucked me up too.
But like, when you can like kill things, it's like less scary.
Oh my god, I can be a dog?
An evil dog.
Wait, this game looks actually sick.
Oh my god, the best game of the year!
Game of- Oh, I knew it.
I toughened through every other trailer so I can finally be happy when I see this.
This is it, guys.
This is it.
We watched all those other trailers.
So we can finally get to here.
This is what we've waited for.
Finally a game that's game of the year.
Nidaveh, thank you for the 100 videos!
Thank you, thank you!
Okay, but the transition between the fucking spooky, scary Slitherhead game to Killer Bean like, I got the whiplash!
Fucking whiplash!
It's like Slitherhead, creators of Silent Hill.
Anyway, here's Killer Bean.
Well, it is sure nice to meet you.
Before you die.
What the fuck?
Oh my god, look, they have asses!
Oh my god, it's already perfect.
It's already perfect.
Oh my god.
They made me who I am.
Okay, those water graphics.
You can pay for it.
Those water gra- What the fuck is the logo?
Glad you liked that one.
That was Killer Bean, a third-person roguelike shooter made by another single developer, believe it or not, right here in Los Angeles.
I mean, I'm not- okay.
I'm not surprised because Killer Bean, the movie, was also made by a single developer.
Or single uh, animator.
I mean, I'm not surprised.
Guys, Killer Bean's a roguelike.
We have to buy it.
Hello, Jeff, everyone.
I'm very happy to be here.
When we created our studio, Aymeric and I, we promised each other to always come up with something new.
Wait, guys, we can make Killer Bean win the Steam Awards.
Because it's a popular vote.
Guys, we have to unite together for the Killer Bean to win an award.
in this position to mount K2.
But half of this team didn't come back.
And I've always wondered why do alpinists risk their lives in such extreme conditions.
This is something we wanted to explore in Cairn.
Cairn is a game about what it takes to go beyond your limits.
Cairn?
You climb a mountain to reach a summit never reached before.
And the climbing gameplay is a challenge.
Wait, it's a climbing game?
A difficult game about climbing but like RTX on?
And what you're going to see in the trailer is not from cutscenes.
It's the actual climbing gameplay.
You can see more later today during Day of the Devs.
But now let's have a look.
Getting over it too?
The Game Bakers.
Wait, it is!
Wait!
It is a difficult game about climbing but like RTX on!
But this time he's wearing clothes!
Oh my god, this is actually anxiety inducing.
Okay, I was going to say we have to look at...
He has clothes and hair!
Oh my god, they grow up so fast!
Oh my god, and he was actually a she!
Oh my god, she's shaking.
What the fuck?
It's like super atmospheric.
But people are going to make a speed run out of this.
You're going to see like the speed run of this, she'll just be like jumping.
Like it looks so intense for the speed run of this game.
It looks so like...
It looks so dumb for the speed run.
For the speed run.
Oh!
That's Stanley Parable.
Wait, what?
Another walking simulator?
Wait, they're making a farm game?
What?
Where's my British narrator?
Fiery Bros, we won!
I'll usually check in with Borel, the guy who owns the shop, to see if my help was needed anywhere.
Wait, is this a farm game?
There's chicken.
Chicken!
Sorry.
Copyright distinct free chicken.
Copyright free chicken.
What?
Huh?
What the f...
Bro, she has trauma.
What?
She has PTSD.
What the fuck happened?
Is this not a farm game?
I thought... I thought farm game was supposed to be relaxing.
Stress farm game?
Haha.
This does not look relaxing now.
And I!
I do.
What's this?
These are incredible.
They call themselves the Sahin.
Nine among them were chosen and shielded from death.
The unknown nine.
Does this have anything to do with why Vincent is here?
What is this?
Humanity has lived for eons at the mercy of the nine.
It's time we took control of our own destiny.
Why are you so interested in Vincent?
Is this Forsaken?
Give us someone I loved.
Oh my god, the bad guy is British.
Find your target and bridge the gap.
You don't belong here.
You're wrong.
This is exactly where I'm meant to be.
Classic.
God, I hope.
Unknown nine.
Oh, it's...
It's a new IP.
The fort is a strange place.
Unknown nine awakening.
It's a new IP.
Right?
I don't know.
It would be really sad if it's not a new IP.
Hey!
How about we see the world together?
I finally found something that I want to protect.
I'll steal your heart.
Adventure starts.
Monster Hunter Stories.
You know what I wish was...
I wish they'd bring to PC?
That one Monster Hunter game where it was just the cats.
I wish they'd just release a Monster Hunter game where...
Like, re-release that PC...
That game to PC where it's just the cats.
That shit was fire.
Yeah.
The village was...
I don't want to play the humans.
I want to play the fucking cats.
That...
Wait, who said that in my chat?
Bro!
That's a broken fan right there.
That fan is...
He goes in there with zero expectation.
On guard.
Your greatest...
Fun.
Wait, is this Colin?
Is this Conquistador?
Dark Souls?
No way.
Spanish Soul.
Oh my god, they have guns!
The fuck?
Where is but one certainty in the cosmos?
Change.
Wait, it is.
Wait a minute.
It is...
Wait, it is Conquistador Souls.
That's so interesting.
Oh my god.
It actually is.
Oh, it's Italian.
I thought it was the Spanish Inquisition.
Is it Italian Souls instead of...
Wait, but I thought it was the Spanish Inquisition.
Was it not?
Was it the Italian?
The Italians had it.
Is this Anthem?
I like how people are debating if it's Spanish or Italian.
But the developers were Italian.
But then I thought it was the Spanish Inquisition.
So it's not the Spanish Inquisition?
Oh,
it's not.
It is Italian.
It's Italian!
It was Italian all along.
It literally says the game is called, guys.
Yeah, but like...
We're all Jokey Bird fans and none of us fucking can read or listen.
It has to be like put in our face.
But the game is called.
We need them to repeat it like three to four times.
I like how they're like, don't lump us in with you, but then everybody above him and below him are like, true!
July 2, 2024.
Oh, the first descendant.
Awesome.
The first descendant will be available across PlayStation, Xbox, and Steam.
I mean, I like the bunny helmet.
Prepare for the release on July 2.
Let's hope it's not like the anthem.
And now, please welcome two developers whose hit indie game, Among Us, took the world by storm and a couple of game awards.
Wait, they're gonna make a new game?
New IP?
From Innerslock, here are Victoria Tran and Forrest Willard.
Among Us 2!
What's up, gamers?
We want the sequel!
Can you believe they just let us be on this stage?
In 3D!
Can we announce something totally fake?
Do you think they'll let us do that?
Among Us 2?
Among Us 3?
Oh my god, Among Us 2!
Turns out we actually have something very real we wanted to present to you all today.
There's been so many great indie games in recent years.
Among Us 2, Among Us, Among Us are here.
It's no secret that it's kind of a rough time in the industry.
Some devs don't really get the chance they deserve, so we thought we could help out a little bit.
That's why we're excited to announce our side project, Outer Sloth.
An indie game fund we made that offers the kind of deals we would have wanted back in our less popular Among E days.
This is our way of saying thank you to our crewmates, players, peers, by helping some games and devs have the funding and freedom needed to ship their games.
Publisher.
And then we all get to play them, which was the real plan.
Or like a publisher, but like they don't, they're just giving money away for free.
Outer Sloth is our passion project and dream for a better, more sustainable industry.
We are really excited.
Yeah, Jeff!
Why are we getting games anymore?
To reveal it here and show you the current line up of games we managed to find.
What's going on?
Say it out loud!
And don't worry Jeff, it has your favorite, a ton of world premieres.
Enjoy!
I can't remember the last time I played it.
I'm so sorry!
Hi,
I'm Iain from Shapeshop, and you may already be playing our first game, Mars First Logistics.
Oh my god, you get to build your own Mars Rover!
We are Trinket Studios, creators of Battle Chef Brigade, and this is our card battler RPG, Ases.
We are Studio Any% and we're making the Marsfield Archives, a game about building Oh wait, I remember Battleship.
Wait,
that's like my type of game.
I just have to press one button.
I don't have to make up this excuse being like I forgot how to play the game anymore.
Hi, I'm Eka, creative director of Outerloop Games, makers of Thirsty Suitors, and Falcon Age.
In our new game, explore the world in an upgradable mech and cook up tasty dishes for local communities.
Fight off corpos, discover new DOSA recipes, and reunite with your strange loved ones for one last meal.
Project DOSA is a game about life, death, love, and food for the soul.
I wonder why they really hate corporations.
Jeff!
Those all look fantastic and I cannot wait to play them.
I wonder if he got laid off somewhere.
Did you know that there's going to be an Among Us TV show?
Oh yeah!
Yeah, Randy's gonna be in it.
There's going to be an Among Us TV show.
Check out this sneak peek.
Oh yeah.
Some of the fucking craziest voice acting.
Voice actors.
Bro, some of the craziest high profile voice actors are in there.
Some of the craziest high profile voice actors are in there.
There's a goth Among Us?
This is a fucking lie!
Where are my goth cosmetics?
Yeah, Patton Oswalt, Elijah Wood.
Yeah, Randall Park.
Elijah Wood is in it, guys.
Up next, we have Sonic X Shadow Generations.
Give him a gun!
A definitive greatest hit collection of 3D and 2D levels from Sonic and Shadow's history.
Don't be a coward!
Now it's time for the glimpse of Shadow's brand new powers.
Give him a gun!
And gameplay from the standalone campaign.
As well as the official release date announcement.
No, why would Shado... Sonic?
No, I'm talking about fucking Shadow!
Shadow!
It's already canon!
Just let him have his gun!
Let Shadow say fuck!
I mean, it would be part of his character.
Oh shit, Metal Sonic?
Oh, goodbye Metal Sonic.
That was fast.
No gun.
If Shadow doesn't have a gun, how can we tell who's Sonic and who's Shadow?
What the fuck?
He has venom?
Woah, what?
What the fuck is that?
What was that Sonic skin on the left?
Shadow the symbiote.
Oh, dude!
Lady Jessica conceives a child.
She banged.
Yeah, I was gonna say, who the fuck is Terios?
It was Shadow's original design?
He was gonna be called Terios?
Until it created me.
But I see a narrow way.
A path that might have been.
What if my mother had obeyed her orders and given birth to a girl?
How do you obey that?
You can't just...
I will now give birth to a girl.
How's Atreides surviving the Battle of Arrakeen?
She chose?
Oh, in Dune you can.
Oh, okay.
No, I've never seen Dune.
The only thing I knew about Dune was the fucking...
The popcorn holder.
I didn't know that.
I just know about the popcorn holder in Dune.
Lisan al-Ghaib.
So I was like, how the fuck did she choose?
All of my visions lead to horror.
Except for this one.
This one leads to you.
Dune Awakening.
More Dune Awakening coming at Gamescom ONL in August.
Now it is time to see the announcement.
of another new game from a brand new development studio.
Oh.
Lightspeed Studios.
Ooh.
I like the animation already.
That's really, really good.
You guys hear that studio that made...
Evangelion is about for bankruptcy and closing down their studios?
Because of tax fraud?
Yeah.
I was like, because of tax fraud.
I was like, yeah.
Okay.
Wow.
Yeah.
That's crazy.
I did not realize.
Yeah.
The...
What was it?
Was it the CEO?
Like the CEO and somebody else in the company...
Committed tax fraud?
Actually...
Look...
Here is the David Kim from Uncapped Games.
Thanks, Jeff.
So Battle Aces is the RTS game for everyone.
It's for players that are brand new to RTS as well as RTS games.
Oh, my God!
An RTS game?
We really want to bring the core form of RTS to everybody.
I thought it went extinct?
Holy shit.
Oh, my God!
I was so surprised this was an RTS game.
RTS is 2024.
What a year.
Give me Zerg class!
Nobody wants to play as Robots.
Okay, maybe I like Robots, but like...
But like, people need different types of classes.
I wanna play as Robots.
Give us Robot Zerg!
Haha.
I can't lie, I wanna play as a Robot.
Thank you, David!
That was fantastic!
Make them sexy!
Our next premiere unveils the exciting new destination for a game that shadow-dropped at the Game Awards last year, the Finals, with its unparalleled destruction, wrapping the world's most deadly game show.
Now, after dozens of updates and two seasons, we're unveiling where contestants will be going in the all-new season starting next week on June 13th.
Sharpen your katanas!
And welcome to...
Season 3 of the Finals.
She's so real for that.
If they hit that reset button...
I am so surprised they're making an RTS in 2024.
I thought they went extinct.
Is this the Finals?
It's still alive?
Oh my god, you can play as a sushi chef?
Wait, what?
Okay, guess who...
Bro, one has guns!
The other has swords!
Like...
Sorry, but like...
Bro, what is a wooden bow gonna do?
The one is winning.
Bro, he has a...
It's a...
What the fuck?
Okay, nevermind.
The ninja proved me wrong.
Holy shit.
Okay, I...
Okay, they're not rude.
The ninja proved...
Oh my god, he went full ninja.
The Finals in Kyoto.
And Genji deflects.
Alright.
Please welcome multiple Game Awards winner and a dazzling Game Awards performer, if I do say so myself.
Sam Lake from Gravity!
Bro, gamers get hungry.
I can't believe it.
What the fuck?
Oh, Alan Wake too.
Oh, it's him!
It's the Alan Wake guy!
I think that's enough.
Thank you.
It's him!
Hi.
You see, this is now the only way...
Alan Wake in my lake.
...they let me come on stage to tell you something exciting.
Alan Wake 3?
News about Alan Wake 2.
Many of you have been posting your Remedy Game collection pictures on your shows.
With Alan Wake 2, so far, digital only, sadly missing.
Well, we are excited to announce...
Max Payne?
...physical deluxe editions...
...and physical collector's editions...
Physical copies?
...for Alan Wake 2, coming this fall.
You can lock in your copy starting tomorrow.
I don't have a disc.
Who the fuck has a disc?
Who has a disc holder on their PC anymore?
...some expansion content for Alan Wake 2.
Right?
I'm thrilled to introduce you all to...
Me?
...nice things.
That's not a cup holder?
It contains three episodes with three familiar, fan-favorite, playable characters...
Okay, there are consoles.
...in mysterious, terrifying, and quirky...
I can't wait to play in 60 frames, guys.
...and quirky.
...what-if scenarios.
It was a chance for us to really go out there...
...as if we already didn't.
Night Springs will be playable...
Now?
...in less than 24 hours.
Oh, okay.
Tomorrow.
Thank you.
I mean, that's pretty fast.
Is it free?
Now, with this world premiere...
...I invite you to step into...
...Night Springs.
Is it free?
Night Springs.
A special place.
A shifting space.
Existing in a countless number of parallel realities.
Different every time we set upon the road that leads us there.
It's free after I buy it.
That's so true.
Yeah, I haven't owned a physical copy of video games in a very long time.
My PC does not have a cup holder in, like, years.
And I will come back for you.
Well, thank you for the tier one sub.
Thank you, thank you.
Yeah, I just buy digital copies of stuff now.
Because they don't do...
They don't do the cool game manuals anymore.
I was the only one who could save the writer...
...and the very soul of murder.
Oh my god, the waitress?
Oh, you can play as other characters now?
I mean, in Outwake 2 you can too, but, like...
But, like, character...
You can play as the waitress?
Exclusive to Deluxe...
You need the Deluxe Edition?!
Through the endless time...
Did you see that?
It's so... It was so tiny.
Did you... Did you see me?
Did you see the text?
It was so tiny too.
It was, like, exclusive to Deluxe Edition.
A beautiful paradise.
Where primal forces clash.
The island's deepest...
...secrets.
Where ancient mysteries awaken.
Guys, I can only read when I want to know if it's free or not.
That's the only time I can read.
This...
...is eternal.
Did you guys know that...
...Amazon games...
Netflix has games as well?
That's right.
New World Aeternum will launch on PS5, Xbox Series X and S, and PC on October 15th.
And now you can play the game start to finish as a solo player, or play co-op and use cross-play as well.
If you're watching SGM on TikTok Live right now, you can comment HSR in the chat to claim your special in-game bundle for Honkai Star Rail of Stellar Jade from TikTok Game Rewards.
Cool.
TikTok Game Awards?
Bro, that's gonna...
Guys, we gotta get this TikTok sponsored before it's shut down in January.
...featuring a beloved character who is clearly ready for the forthcoming journey with her brand new look.
Oh my god.
One of my staff in my team was like, you should...
...you should make an Instagram...
...and start uploading your TikTok videos to Instagram.
Because, like, we don't know if TikTok's still gonna be here after January.
She was like, I think it'd be a good idea.
Just so, like, you know, if they ban TikTok, like, you don't just lose everything.
You're Canadian, though.
That should be fair.
Yeah, but a lot of my fans are American!
Isn't Instagram gonna steal your content for their AI?
Every company has already downloaded my fucking image.
If Google hasn't done it yet, then, like, it's fine.
Why do people choose to swear?
Because in the end...
...what's happening?
Gacha.
It's Hong Kong Star Rail.
It's just Gacha.
That's why, like, Gacha sponsors, they pay so much money to sponsor you.
Dark and Darker is still...
...alive?
Oh, the reason why Gacha games...
...pay a lot to sponsor you...
...is it's been alive.
Bro, guys, Dark and Darker, you can play Dark and Darker whenever still.
Like...
Oh, it got back on Steam?
Okay, I'm just saying, because, like, Dark and Darker died so fast...
...because they, uh...
...uh, from what Surefour told me, they, like, removed a lot of stuff in there that made it fun.
So I don't know if they add it back in.
Yeah, the game balance was really bad.
And that's why it got, like...
...like, people stopped playing it.
What the fuck?
So I don't know if they added the fun...
OH MY GOD, YOU CAN BE A BEAR!
Nevermind, everything...
...nevermind.
It's back.
Dark and Darker is back.
That is...
The funnest game is saved.
We're so back, boys!
The game is saved!
There you have it, the unforgiving fantasy FPS dungeon PvP...
We're so back.
...the adventure Dark and Darker is now live on both Steam and Epic Games Store today.
So play it this weekend, alright?
Oh my god.
Alright, next week we're playing Dark and Darker.
I'm gonna be a fucking bear.
We're gonna bring it to our VIP section thanks to the Discover Orange...
Why is there nobody sitting there?
Discover, you don't have to be a VIP to be treated like one.
Alright, now here's the announcement of the release date...
...for Capcom's upcoming Kunitsugami Path of the Goddess.
The empty...
Those are our seats.
Why is there an empty row of seats?
Wait, what was I talking about before I saw the bear?
Before I saw the bear...
...I started talking about...
...the Dark and Darker shit.
Capcom is giving something.
Oh yeah, Gatcha.
Alright, Gatcha pays a lot for sponsors...
...cause all they need is to hook one person.
Really.
The moment they hook one person into a Gatcha game...
...like, they already made back the money for the sponsor.
Yeah, as long as one person is a whale...
...like...
...that's so real.
That's all they need.
What's this?
Is this Risco Rain?
It feels like Risco Rain.
Hyper Light?
What's Hyper Light?
Risco Rain 3.
We added another co-op player.
Hyper Light.
It is Hyper Light.
No way that's Hyper Light.
I will cream.
Alright.
Come on.
Don't expose him like that.
Peta hates this game.
Peta hates everything.
You can't say that.
Peta...
Peta hates everything.
Peta's whole strategy is to hate...
...and cause like...
...like, cause like controversy...
...cause they're in the internet.
Wait, it's that guy from SNL that got fired.
It's time to dispel any of these completely unfounded rumors...
Wait, unless it's not him.
He looks like one of the SNL guys that got fired.
...and the city of San Vanserdam have never been better.
Things are going great here.
We have absolutely nothing to hide from the citizens.
Not him?
Wait, who is he?
Everybody here at...
Who is this guy?
...loves this town?
We think this town rules.
Why would we hurt a town that rules?
This is Tim Robinson?
I can't stop thinking about how you're saying we're selling...
...the city for scraps.
That makes me sick.
That makes my whole family sick to their stomachs.
My wife hasn't been on the toilet for weeks.
He is the SNL guy!
Because of what you say about what M-Corp is doing to this town.
All those lies.
Wait, unless...
Everyone at M-Corp is really good.
Stop crying!
All right?
This is business.
Look around, pal.
This is how businesses are run.
Now, you should have known that...
Oh, he's definitely not.
Guys, sorry.
He's not.
...tissues.
Come on, pal.
Bah!
...
That's not about this.
That's a...
That's a father and son.
That's actually a home issue.
We love it here at M-Corp.
And we are not going anywhere.
Wait, is this not Tim Robinson?
We'll be here a long time.
What's going on?
The leader in Creed...
It is Tim Robinson?
I fucking knew it!
I know my SNL guy!
A writer!
Writer and performer on the NBC sketch comedy series, Saturday Night Live, from 2012 to 2014!
I fucking knew it!
Hey, Jeff!
How you doing, bud?
I knew...
I know my SNL guy!
They're going to need a lot of cleaning that up.
That's bad.
Is this gay?
It's real!
What an ad.
I thought it was something regarding corporate stuff.
But it was just...
It was Sk8.
I was going to say, it was just Sk8.
But I know my chat was like, it's not just Sk8!
I meant, like, but it's Sk8.
Oh,
console playtesting.
Console playtesting?
Very exciting that people will finally be able to play Sk8 on PC.
It'll be available on console in the near future.
Our next world premiere of Indie Censation from Japan is...
Get escape the poor thing.
...is why...
...it has over 25 million players worldwide.
That's right, I'm talking about PAL World.
Wait, PAL World?!
I mean, just look at the giant depresso.
Sure buddy.
Wow!
Summer game test.
Now, here's the first major update announcement.
Guys, this is why Nintendo doesn't let Jeff play.
A whole new island is coming.
This is why Nintendo doesn't join in on Jeff's stuff.
I know!
I like how Jeb was like, I wish, I hope Nintendo comes back to us.
And then they released this.
Did you guys see that?
Oh shit, New Island!
Did you guys see that news article where Jeb was saying I hope Nintendo one day rejoins the the shows.
Oh shit.
Wait, the new update looks fucking sick.
Oh my god, finally.
Finally something subspecies.
Oh no.
Jeb, you fucked up, Jeb.
I don't think Nintendo's gonna come back.
Oh my god, oil rigs?
Wait, this is rust!
Arena?
Oh shit, wait, this is sick!
Wait, the arenas look sick.
Yeah, the PVP.
What is this?
Sakura update.
Oh wait, hey, that's like this month!
That's this new waifu.
Valorant.
Valorant?
New character?
Thanks, Jeb.
Hey, everyone.
Since 2020, we have been fortunate to serve players in their pursuit of what we call the Valorant moment.
Oh my god, we can have a Power Dragoon server!
That'd be so fun.
For members.
Millions of players all over the world have earned their own Valorant moments on PC.
And today, the stage is set to welcome a whole new group of players.
Let's take a look.
Valorant?
Mobile?
Oh, console?
There's no way they're gonna put crossplay.
There's no way.
But, where is it?
Why?
But...
I guess if they hook console players in, they have more people buy skins?
They want more people to buy skins?
Because I'm just like, thinking, why would Huni put Valorant on console?
It'd be smart, honestly, it'd be smarter to put it on mobile rather than console.
More people would...
Because like, a lot of people in Asia play FPS games on mobile.
Because it's very popular.
That was Valorant's core tactical gameplay.
Everything you just saw was captured on console and with a controller.
Valorant is coming to PlayStation 5 and Xbox Series X and S this year.
Our limited beta starts June 14th.
And you can sign up right now at beta.playvalorant.com We are so excited for your input to make sure that Valorant plays great on console.
And we hope to see you soon.
But before we go, here's the head of Valorant's studio, Anna Donlan.
Thanks, guys.
Hey, everyone.
One of my favorite things about Valorant has been seeing the community build the game and the sport right along with us.
Is this a VCT?
We have been on the most amazing journey, bringing Valorant to players all around the world, most recently to China, where I'm currently a Valorant Masters one of our largest global tournaments and community celebrations.
Oh, shit.
VCT is on now?
Oh, it's in Shanghai?
That's what I'm saying.
There's no way they're gonna have a competitive... There's more of a chance to have a competitive Valorant mobile team than a competitive console team for Valorant.
There's like...
There's like big esports for mobile gaming.
They might as well just put it as a mobile game versus a console.
And mobile games are already used to spending money.
All I'm saying is that mobile games are already used to spending money on gacha and skins.
True.
Look at Mobile Apex.
Mobile Apex died so fast not because of the lack of a player base.
That's all I'm gonna say.
It was more so of like legal stuff.
Because if you guys didn't know, the company that made Apex Mobile made their own version of Apex afterwards.
Because it's a different company.
A different company made the Apex Mobile.
And then they yoinked it and like made their own version after that.
And it's popular by the way.
It's It's popular too.
Thanks to the team at Riot for sharing that with us here at SGF.
Our next announcement is a big deal from our friends at DoorDash.
Five weeks of deals with Summer of Dash Pass.
Guys sign up for DoorDash now for $0 delivery fees.
Get 50% off your next DoorDash quarter.
Oh my god they know gamers don't cook.
Or they're not don't cook but they're too lazy.
This is an amazing voice actor.
He knows what they see.
Such as Like a Dragon and God of War Ragnarok.
Well next week Yong is going to be voicing a character in a movie Inside Out 2 where he plays a fictional video game character Lance Slashblade.
And we've got your exclusive first look.
Check this out.
Welcome to your eternal fate.
Lance Slashblade?
But he's a video game character.
Why is he here?
Why is a movie here?
Pixar sponsored this?
I wanted to be a hero.
Pixar was in the same same show as the other game that got released where they were smoking some.
Don't you dare say that.
You do not deserve to be thrown away.
Oh my god.
Don't you remember his power move?
I'm coming for you Riley.
No one is totally worthless.
A warrior cursed with a feeble attack.
Then you must make your curse your gift.
It's a Pixar trailer.
Shield yourself my friends for I shall set you all free.
Okay.
Alright.
Not gonna lie.
The fact that Pixar was was in was in the Summer Game Fest and the third trailer we saw was like a group of prisoners, you know doing some things.
It's kinda wild.
And yes, Chicken does look a lot like Ken Jeong.
And today Chicken is excited to share a new game that Chicken and Chicken's buddies are in called Squad Busters.
You fight monsters collect lots of shiny things and Chicken has a big role.
I know some of you guys are saying it might be cringe.
And here it is.
Like this trailer is cringe?
Or like you're like wow this is embarrassing and sad.
It's not that sad because you know damn well Ken Jeong just got paid at least $500,000 just to be there for like just to be in a one minute trailer.
laughter laughter laughter laughter I should keep the definition of fun.
I am butt naked from the waist down so.
Get out of the f baikin bed dude.
Respect the gray.
Sign me up.
Bro this tro is in here?
Holy shit what, what was there was no budget Chris Hemsworth is in here.
There no budget.
You know damn well Well, Chris Hemsworth was paid at least a million dollars.
No, this game company!
Bro, was it Brawl Stars?
It's like one of the three.
It's like Raid Shadow Legends where they're everywhere.
I've been wrong!
I've been down!
Look at these clowns.
You call this a squat?
Oh yeah, Clash of the Clans, yeah.
Pathetic.
Imposter.
Jinx.
No, you Jinx.
Are you supposed to be a lumberjack?
Yeah, Clash of the Clans is crazy profitable apparently.
Oh my god!
This is a long trailer.
They spent... they paid Jeff a lot of money.
Bro, Clash of the Clans is even in the Super Bowl ads.
Was it Clash Royale?
Clash of Clans?
It's either Clash of Clans...
It's one of them.
It's one of the screaming...
Screaming Man icons.
You know the mobile game used with the screaming man?
It's one of them.
Oh, Squad Busters.
Alright, please join me in welcoming to the SGF stage Monster Hunter series producer, Mr. Ryozo Tujimono!
Ryozo-san!
Like, you guys might be like, who plays this game?
Normies.
Normies play this game.
Normie plays Clash of Clans, guys.
A lot of normies.
Thank you, Jeff.
Normies are not watching this.
That's why they have a trailer for this!
They want non-Normies too!
I want everyone to be on the lookout for a very mysterious large monster near the end of the trailer, as it's an important monster within the game.
Yes, in this game, we are working on a combination of immersion and action.
Monster Hunter Wilds will be available on the PlayStation 5, Xbox Series X, and PC in 2025.
And it will be released on PC at the same time.
Also, this time, we will be playing it with you for more than 100 years.
He's trying to be like, alright, bye!
Bye!
I like how the translator was about to say something.
As you'll see, we are working to deliver a gaming experience that merges immersion and action.
I hope players look forward to playing with their friends across different platforms when the game launches simultaneously in 2025 on PlayStation 5, Xbox Series X and S, and PC.
This is the last part.
The opening night live of Gamescom will be held in August.
We will bring you a new video.
Oh my god, there's cross-play?
Oh my god, you can play with your Switch friends!
And yell at them!
For their 30 friends!
Lastly, there will be a new trailer for Monster Hunter Wilds at opening night live at Gamescom in August.
And our first public hands-on playable demo of Monster Hunter Wilds will also debut at Gamescom.
Literally every- Wait, they're releasing everywhere but the Switch?
Oh my god.
Sorry, Nintendo.
The Switch cannot run this game.
It's so weird hearing them, like, talk.
Like, actual words.
I swear, they don't usually- I feel like- Do you know what I mean?
Some of the characters used to, like, have their own language.
Oh my god, show us the PP dragon!
You know, that one!
Oh my god!
I don't like the mouth.
That mouth makes me uncomfortable!
Woah!
He's gripping!
I'm so- Somebody akasupan!
Somebody akasupan in the Game Awards channel!
Yeah, Jeff!
Have some more money, Jeff!
Wooo!
Thank you!
We will see you at Gamescom in August.
During last year's PlayStation Showcase, the game Phantom Blade Zero from S-Game wowed us all with its blazing fast combat and stylish art.
Well, I'm honored to share with you the brand new trailer for the game featuring all real gameplay.
Here's our final game of the show, Phantom Blade Zero!
Ooh, Phantom Blade Zero.
This looks good.
Gameplay trailer, gameplay trailer.
Wait, this is the final game?
They're ending it off here?
No!
That can't be!
They always give us a surprise after they say final!
The face of this is here!
You got skaked before so-song, isn't that sad?
Don't.
Don't go up there.
Turn back.
My favorite are the people- No!
Not the horse!
Anyway.
My favorite are the people that were coping about Kingdom Hearts 4.
After Jeff was like, there's no Kingdom Hearts 4.
And everybody was like, sure, Jeff.
No Kingdom Hearts 4.
Sure.
I'm still coping.
There's a lot for you to look for.
Asiq, thank you for the Twitch friend!
Thank you!
I mean, it looks...
Is it Souls?
Is this a Souls-like?
It is.
Yeah, it looks like Sekiro.
Souls.
Oh my god.
What the fuck?
20-24 World Tour, demo.
June 8th.
Oh!
Guys, you guys go to Summer Game Fest right now!
You can play it!
That looks so good.
Full demo of the media you'll be playing this weekend.
That's why people paid a ticket, guys.
This is the reason.
Just for that game.
Thank you, Jeff.
I had such an amazing time.
Happy Summer Game Fest, everyone.
All the people here are like finally the reason why I'm here.
Day of the Devs is coming up live right now on the stream featuring an hour of indie game reveals including the next game from Cappy.
Guys, surprise?
Surprise release?
Surprise trailer?
For other event streams this weekend and we'll see you again live this August 20th in Germany for Gamescom opening night live.
Thanks for watching, everyone.
Remember, Day of the Devs starts right now.
It can't be the last one.
What?
Surprise trailer?
Where's the surprise trailer?
Oh, wow.
Where's?
the gotcha moment?
Coming in with a steel chair Uh.
Alright we don't care about Day of the devs.
We love Devs, but we don't really care right now.
The surprise moment was that there was no surprise... NOOOOO!
What do you mean there was no surprise!
Alright, no, I think the most funny part was somebody Akasupa-ing.
One of the most funny parts.
Wait, let me see who- I'm gonna read their Akasupa.
There's two Akasupas?!
Somebody donated 200 euros!
Somebody Aka'd Aka 200 euros!
To, like, knock and tell my mom that Soulstone Survivors is also part of the Summerfest.
Okay, wait.
I'm- I'm trying- I'm reading.
Okay, this is the other- This is the other Akas- The other Akasup.
Okay.
I'm edging this entire stream until Dragon Ball Z Sparking or Batman VR comes out.
Holy shit.
Bro, this man has- This king low has expectations, bro.
Why was one of them Batman VR?
Like, wha- Like, out of all the games, this guy's most hyped out about Batman VR.
Exclusively on the meta quest.
Like, what?!
My god, bro.
God.
He's almost like that chatterer about Capcom.
Woo!
Go Capcom!
Give us nothing!
That- That comment, there's, like, Renfree in my head.
That actually was so good.
He's picking up a broken-ass man.
Yeah- It's just that it's Renfree!
Like...
Aw, I'm so...
Oh my gosh, I'm so sad that the Wukong game did not have...
Uh, did not have more...
Uh, did not have gameplay trailer.
I would've loved to see more gameplay trailer of that game.
Cause it looks pretty!
But...
It looks pretty, but like...
I wanna see gameplay!
I wanna see more gameplay.
That's what I wanted.
But we didn't get that.
Also, also, great!
Good news!
Uh...
I just wanna give you guys an update.
About...
Um...
About the U2's figure.
So, like...
Uh...
We're gonna have...
Um...
Cause I know there's, like, restricted countries.
But, um...
I know we have a lot of dragoons in South Korea and the Philippines.
So, like, I convinced U2's to open shipping.
For, like...
Uh...
Cause, like, Philippines was a restricted country.
Um...
And I convinced U2's to let, like, Filipino dragoons to be able to order...
Uh...
The U2's figure.
Just for my figure.
Um...
And...
Right now, we're trying to work on South Korea as well, too.
We're trying to include South Korea right now.
Um...
Into, like...
Uh...
The...
Into, like, people can order the U2's figure.
Yes.
I basically was, like...
Oh, I have a lot of fans.
I know I have a lot of Filipino dragoons and a lot of South Korean dragoons.
And, like, I really wanna open pre...
If we can, like...
I know, like, you guys are...
Usually, it's a restricted country for shipping and stuff.
Um...
But, like, could we please have it open just for my figure?
And they're, like, yeah, we can work on it.
And right now, they successfully have for Philippines.
We're now working on South Korea at the moment.
We're working on that.
Uh...
So, I haven't tweeted it out yet.
Cause I'm gonna see if we can.
I'm gonna see if we can.
Um...
And it's just for my U2's figure, too.
It's just for mine.
Cause I was, like, I know you guys...
I...
I got you guys.
I know you...
I saw a lot of people were like...
We're crying about it.
So, I was like, please.
I...
But don't worry.
I got you.
I was, like, specifically asking them if they could make an exception for me.
And they're, like, yeah, yeah.
We're gonna work on it.
Like...
So, I'm not sure.
I'm not tweeting it out yet.
I'm just gonna wait until, like, they...
They have South Korea in the shipping options.
And then, I'll tweet it out.
Um...
But, yeah.
Alright.
So...
Uh...
Tomorrow, I do have a collab.
So...
I'm gonna have a collab with Amelie and Zentreya in Apex.
But I think I won't be streaming my POV.
Because I'm still...
I wanna be, like, more chill.
Because I didn't really get to rest a lot this week.
So...
Um...
So, I'm gonna be doing...
I'm gonna be...
Have no POV.
But I'll retweet either Amelie or Zentreya's stream.
Um...
Anyway.
Next week will be a solo...
Solo stream week.
Next week.
Uh...
Since, like, the last three weeks.
We went from Tekken week to WrestleTuber week.
And then to...
And then to Minecraft week.
So next week will be solo stuff.
Because I just wanna hang out with my dragoons next week.
We had so many collabs in the last three weeks.
So next week is just gonna be gaming stuff with the dragoons.
Or, like, not with...
Not maybe with the dragoons.
But just...
Hang out with the dragoons.
With some solo content.
Uh...
So, yeah.
That's gonna be next week's plan.
I don't...
Yeah.
And I...
My social batteries ran out.
Like, a hundred percent.
I'm so...
I...
I'm so tired.
I'm so...
Also, another update!
We finally...
Finally...
Have...
I know I told you guys we have a distributor.
But the distributor has received the packages.
Which means...
Um...
They are starting to ship stuff out today.
They are giving an update.
They are starting to ship things out today.
The bundles...
Although I do have a little bad news.
The bundles will be...
Still be a little bit delayed because we had a small manufacturing error.
I will be making a full statement of this on Twitter.
I was just waiting for the distributor to send me a picture of all the orders being...
Of all the package orders that they're sending out today.
Um...
But the bundles will be a little bit delayed because we had a manufacturing order so we're We're waiting for the manufacturer to send in the new stuff.
Not like to send in the merch to fix it.
So we're still waiting for that.
But the debut merch is starting to ship out today.
So good news!
Yay!
Good news!
I'll give you guys a recap on the latest Minecraft drama on YouTube, by the way.
But I'll just give you guys an update.
It was so funny, because yesterday, more shit went down.
And the finals... Okay, the finals for that Minecraft event was fucking Connect Four.
It was Connect Four.
And there was a two-hour stalemate on fucking Connect Four.
That the two finalists ended up splitting the money.
Because they were in a stand-off.
Because they knew if they make a move, they'd lose the 70k.
So there was like a two-hour fucking stand-off.
Until they're like, just split the money.
They were like, organizers, just let us split the money.
If you don't split the money, we won't play.
It was so bad!
So they ended up splitting the 2k.
That's right, they ended up splitting the 70k.
Yeah, the 70k ended up getting split.
Anyway guys, they held everybody hostage.
It was crazy.
It was like actual Hunger Games shit with like PETA and Katniss, where there were two winners.
Anyway guys, I'm gonna call it here.
I'll see you guys soon on Amelie or Zentreya's stream.
For those who are new here, I usually stream on the YouTubes.
So please!
Check me on YouTube.
I'm usually on Twitch for like, watch-alongs or for like, specific events.
Like today, where I was doing the Twitch watch-along.
But like I said, sometimes I am on...
Sometimes I'm here on Twitch, where like, yeah, but like mostly I'm on YouTube.
This week I was mostly on Twitch because of the Minecraft Twitch event and also this watch-along.
I usually do all my watch-alongs here.
Did I just get raided?
Oh my god!
Rosie, thank you for the raid!
I'm gonna pass it forward because I'm literally about to end.
But thank you everybody!
I just finished my watch-along so I was just about to end.
But thank you for the raid!
Thank you for the raid, Rosie Bell!
But yeah, for those who are new here, please check me out on YouTube.
I'll be back on YouTube next week.
But yeah, I didn't intend to do a whole week of streaming on Twitch.
But like...
You know, I didn't intend to be on day four, but it happened.
For the Minecraft.
Anyway, if you want to support me via other means, please check out my merch.
And if you want to know when I stream on Twitch, please follow me on Twitter.
Because I always tweet out when I'll be live on Twitch on Twitter.
I tweet out when I'll be live on Twitch.
So yeah, follow me on Twitter.
Anyway, I think that's everything.
Thank you all for the subs.
For the gifted subs.
For the donations.
And for all the followers, I really appreciate it.
Hey guys, as always everybody, stay hydrated, posture checked, get up and move around to get that blood flowing.
And if you stay up for me, head to bed.
Because you deserve it.
I'll see you guys next time, everybody.